oui
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans la grande
interview je me trouve aujourd'hui avec
jenia grebennikov le libéro de l'équipe
de france de volley ball championne
olympique à tokyo l'été dernier qui nous
reçoit dans l'enceinte de son club du
zenit saint pétersbourg genia bonjour
bonjour genia depuis votre victoire le
site n 9 août dernier contre la russie à
tokyo avez vous l'impression que vous
êtes plus attendu de la part de vos
adversaires on peut penser à 7 euros un
peu moins aboutie bien sûr je pense que
déjà on était déjà attendue avant cette
victoire au jeu c'est vrai que ça nous
met une pression en plus parce que voilà
faut vous montrer à tout le monde et
continue à le démontrer qu'on est l'une
des meilleures équipes du monde
c'est vrai que maintenant tout le monde
on est l'équipe à abattre un peu parce
qu'on met on est champions jusqu'à paris
on fait le max au travail est la preuve
que
que tout le monde veut nous abattre à
l'euro on a perdu contre les tchèques
une équipe qui est soi-disant inférieur
à nous
c'est ça le danger c'est ne pas rester
posés sur ce qu'on a réalisé auparavant
mais continue à progresser travailler
pour pour encore rapporté des titres à
la france et continue à grandir tous
ensemble et donner le meilleur de
nous-mêmes mais c'est vrai que ça va
être ça va être très difficile et de
plus en plus difficile dans le futur
j'aimerais maintenant revenir sur votre
sur votre histoire personnelle sur votre
parcours vous êtes né à rennes en 1990
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
comment comment vous êtes arrivé comment
votre famille est arrivée en bretagne
alors chers vivait
en bretagne à rennes en fait après le
départ de ma famille de mon père et ma
mère
qui sont partis en 1989 c'était un des
premiers sportifs à s'en aller et il ya
rennes qui l'accueille un club qui
l'accueille où il se retrouve en fait
mes deux parents se retrouvent avec avec
rien du tout dans une ville inconnue
sans parler la langue sans parler
l'anglais et d'où venaient-ils
exactement la ville je sais plus mais
c'est vrai qu' ils sont arrivés avec
voilà dans une aventure qui partait dans
l'inconnu vraiment
et en fait ça leur a tellement plu la
france la bretagne ça leur a plu rennes
ils ont tellement été bien accueilli
qu'ils ont décidé de de rester là-bas et
de il y avait mon grand frère qui était
déjà la bac et c'est un plus âgé que moi
et du coup ils ont dit bon bah ils ont
dit à mon père a dit à ma mère était
enceinte pourquoi pas ont fait naître
ici et puis on reste ici parce qu'on
sent bien et puis peut-être qu'un projet
avec un club à construire là bas et du
coup ils sont restés ils ont repoussé
chaque année en fait d'un an et puis au
final et ils y sont encore maintenant
aujourd'hui et donc vous avez grandi là
bas vous avez commencé à faire du sport
vous avez comme pas commencer par le
volley ball forcément vous avez fait du
hockey sur glace c'est ça et après est
venu et après est venu le volet comment
comment s'est fait ce choix entre les
deux sports est ce que c'était par
rapport à la qualité par rapport à
peut-être à vos parents vous ont poussée
plus vers un sport que l'autre en fait
tout petit j'ai baigné en fait dans le
volley-ball parce que mon mon grand
frère je volais ma mère était entraîneur
de volley pour les enfants mon père
était professionnel après en fait est
devenu entraîneur aussi pour les ados et
après est devenu entraîneur pour les
pros moi j'ai touché un peu à tout j'ai
aimé tous les sports et des gamins en
fait je voulais devenir sportif sportifs
de haut niveau peu importe le sport du
coup j'ai touché à tout j'ai fait basket
j'ai pas fait de sport individuel je
fais basket foot
après je me suis accroché hockey sur
glace parce que j'avais vu un film à la
télé je me suis dit bon poussé dans les
racines de mon père mon père en avait
fait
j'ai commencé à jouer à jouer je faisais
pas de deux volets en club mais bon
c'était le sport de coeur vu que tout le
monde le pratiquer dans la famille et à
16 ans en fait j'ai dû choisir mon père
m a dit il ya le lycée le hockey sur
glace et le volet on peut pas faire les
trois quoi en plus il était très à
cheval sur mes études il voulait
vraiment que j'ai un bagage avant de me
lancer dans ma carrière dans une
carrière en fait
du coup on a abandonné le hockey sur
glace
parce que
j'ai cru
et je pensais à ce moment là que j'avais
plus de capacité à devenir
sportif de haut niveau au volet du coup
on est parti vers cette direction là en
plus mon père venait d'être nommé
professionnels coach professionnel de
l'équipe a à rennes du coup je me suis
dit ça m'a ouvert des portes parce que
je me suis entraîné très jeune avec
l'équipe pro à rennes et du coup samassa
a augmenté ma progression j'ai vite
monté
et en plus voilages allier les deux
études et et volé et ça me permettait
aussi de rester dans ma famille c'est
pour ça que j'ai eu beaucoup de chance à
ce moment là mais c'est vrai que ma
famille m'a beaucoup aidé et la ville de
rennes aussi m'a beaucoup aidé et ce
choix du poste de libéro comment ça
s'est fait petit à petit parce que c'est
vrai étant jeune je jouais beaucoup à
l'attack j'étais très technique pas très
grand pas très physique je me
débrouillais en fait graal attaque grâce
à ma technique
c'est vrai qu'il y avait des gabarits
beaucoup plus impressionnant que le mien
moi j'étais plus un peu plus vif un peu
plus dynamique sur le terrain
et en fait je voulais tout le temps joué
j'ai toujours eu l'habitude depuis tout
petit de jouer
est en fait dès qu'on met dans un coin
où je peux pas jouer je suis pas bien je
suis triste ça se voie directe sur mon
visage je suis triste et en fait j'ai
commencé ma carrière
en étant en étant sur le banc comme
comme tout le monde en général a parlé d
exception qui commence directement sur
le terrain est en fait au bout de trois
quatre matches j'ai dit à mon père mais
c'est un enfer sur le banc je peux pas
rester sur le banc je déteste ça inhibe
à avoir travaillé au poste de libéro
elle a peut-être que tu auras ta chance
de jouer parce qu'il me disait rien la
taxe n'est pas assez puissante a pas
assez de hauteur du coup j'ai travaillé
j'ai travaillé j'ai travaillé pendant
pas mal de temps déjà je le travail est
un peu ce poste parce que il avait déjà
senti la chose venir il savait que
j'avais pas supporter des sur le banc et
puis voilà on a on a bossé puis au final
après à la moitié de saison il m'a dit
bon bah je te lancer le moment c'est ta
chance et puis j'ai saisi ma chance et
puis depuis j'ai jamais lâcher ce
maillot de libéro vous avez donc grandi
dans une double culture franco russe
est-ce que vous avez considéré ça comme
une chance ouais énormément de chance
parce que en fait
déjà je me trouvais chanceux
de vivre en france après tout ce que mes
parents ont vécu en ex urss
j'avais la chance d'aller voir l'été
aussi ma
famille mes proches et voilà je voulais
qu'ils étaient dans la difficulté on ne
peut pas seul on peut pas se le cacher
et j'ai remercié à chaque fois mais mes
parents de nous avoir emmenés en france
même malgré tous ces sacrifices qu'ils
ont faits parce qu'il voyait plus la
famille il était super bien ça doit être
super dur et nous on les remercie à
chaque fois avec mon grand frère dès
qu'on rentre est parce qu on se sentait
français mais aussi russes on avait les
deux les deux côtés en fait ça nous a
beaucoup surtout apporter le je pense le
respect la chose qui me frappe le plus
c'est le respect que
que les jeunes donnent aux plus anciens
à chaque fois avec ce vouvoiement alors
qu'en france dès fois je pense qu'on
peut le perdre
vraiment ce respect de l'ancien et je
trouve incroyable ici et ça ça m'a
toujours marqué
ce comme des fois on fait quand je viens
ici on m'appelle yevgeny bali savic et
moi c'est quelque chose je leur
demandais mais qu'est ce que c'est
pourquoi pour qu'on m'appelle pas génial
comme tout le monde est en fait j'ai
beaucoup de forme de respect comme ça
qui m'impressionne et puis ça m'a permis
de grandir en tant que personne et voilà
j'ai été élevé à la dure 1
voilà donc vous l'avez pas mal de choses
que ce côté russe m'a donné pas mal de
force on va dire et vous l'avez évoqué
rapidement que connaissez vous
exactement de la russie de vos parents
vous disiez partis en vacances là bas on
partait en vacances je me rappelle moi
j'ai des souvenirs faire les grands
enfin maintenant je les revends vidéo
les vidéos des rares sont situés sur des
cassettes on allait dans une datcha en
fait chez mes grands parents je me
rappelle où on va c'est plein de légumes
je me rappelle il y avait une rivière on
allait à la pêche s'était vraiment il y
avait pas grand chose mais c'était des
moments un coup incroyable conviviale je
me rappelle il ya des moments où on
allait dans le sauna on se baignait dans
enfin vont se jeter dans l'eau froide
j'ai plein de flash en fait de ma
jeunesse qui reviennent après c'est vrai
qu'à partir de 15 ans j allais plus
parce que j'étais sélectionné en équipe
de france mais plein de choses qui me
reviennent on a réagi authentique voilà
ces endroits là c'est ça et ça c'est des
souvenirs qui resteront toujours en moi
parce que voilà ça me rappelait l'était
il ya des odeurs aussi même quand je
suis revenu il y avait des odeurs qui me
reviennent plein de choses comme ça là
je voyais les repas
voilà il y avait le bortsch y avait
plein de choses quartier interlope
éliminé chez tf1 plein de souvenirs qui
me reviennent et puis qui vont marquer
tout au long de ma vie en fait vous avez
connu une progression fulgurante avec
rennes au début puis l'allemagne puis
plusieurs clubs en italie est maintenant
ici au zénith saint pétersbourg qu'est
ce qui a motivé votre choix de venir ici
en russie dès le début de ma carrière en
fait je m'étais dit je m'étais promis en
fait que j'allais venir jouer en russie
j'ai toujours attendu en fait cette
proposition peu importe le club en
russie parce que j'avais envie de
d'avoir dans ma carrière voilà un club
russe malgré la difficulté d'accéder sur
toi mon poste
d'intégrer une équipe russe que il ya
que deux étrangers qui peuvent évoluer
dans le dans l'équipe type en fait dans
le six de départ parce que voilà il
préfère donner la chance aux attaquants
aux pacers les libéraux c'est très rare
de voir des libéraux étrangers en russie
et du coup
ça m'a toujours attiré quoi parce que
voilà j'ai envie de revoir un peu la
russie fait partie de ma vie j'avais
envie de voir comment on y vit le temps
un retour aux racines encaisser ça c'est
ça et surtout voilà ça fait aussi un
petit clin d'oeil à mon père qui lui est
parti à 31 ans de l'urss et moi
justement j'y vais avec ma famille à 31
ans c'est incroyable comme
comme truc parce qu'eux mêmes fins et
même pas fait exprès quoi et c'est vrai
que dès qu'il ya eu cet appel concrets
de du zénith saint pétersbourg j'ai
foncé c'était je me suis même pas posé
la question j'avais vraiment envie et
puis voilà c'est un club qui a toujours
été deuxième j'ai envie de gagner avec e
écrire l'histoire avec eux donc ça
faisait partie des plans on va dire vous
côtoyez dans ce club certains des
meilleurs joueurs de russie
est-ce que vous verriez un jour jouer
avec eux en sélection c'est vrai que la
question elle s'est posée surtout au
début de ma carrière
c'est qu'on n'était pas trop au courant
de
des lois de comment ça se passe des
procédures c'est à réfléchir parce que
comme je disais auparavant en fait il ya
deux le droit qu'à deux étrangers dans
dans l'équipe en fait donc
si je deviens russe cela permettrait
aussi d'avoir un étranger en plus donc
déjà j'aurai moins de soucis à trouver
un club en russie mais ça permettrait
voilà au zénith de saint petersbourg
d'avoir un étranger en plus surtout que
mes racines sont russes renvoyés ça à
réfléchir c'est à penser mais c'est ça
c'est pas passé j'aurais préféré que ça
se passe avant parce que voilà dès l'âge
de mes 18 ans voilà voilà mais j'ai pas
eu de la proposition et même je me
trouvais bien en france voilà j'avais
envie j'avais une bonne bonne bande de
potes donc voila mais peut-être dans
l'avenir mais pourquoi pas pour
justement avoir plus de facilité en club
à trouver un club et à pouvoir rester
aussi ici et c'est une procédure
spéciale et ça demande d'être deux ans
en sélection ça je pense et cela je ne
sais pas exactement les lois mais
pourquoi pas en fin de carrière oui ça
me permettrait d'arrêter en fait deux
ans en équipe en équipe nationale mais
ce serait pas pour évoluer avec la
sélection et j'aurai un peu plus de
difficultés mais ça serait vraiment pour
l'histoire du club en fait pouvoir
évoluer et faire ma saison en club dans
un club russe en tant que russe donc du
coup j'ai l'impression que vous voyez à
moyen long terme rester aussi à préparer
mal après paris 2024 en fait tu l'as
déjà j'ai signé trois ans ici j'espère
pouvoir faire mes trois années si après
paris 2024 j'espère encore rester ici à
voir qui ne sait jamais ce qui peut se
passer dans le volet donc sait jamais ce
qu'il peut se passer avec les contrats
sait jamais ce qui peut se passer aussi
d'un monde on a vu avec la pandémie
locaux vides donc
à voir on sait pas c'est dur de se
projeter sur le futur surtout dans le
monde du sport pouvez vous nous dire
quel a été l'accueil de vos partenaires
ici vos partenaires sur le terrain et du
public russe surtout après avoir battu
la russie en finale des jeux olympiques
n'ont pas super voilà il était content
que sur la avec eux c'est vrai qu'on
sait charriait de trois fois mais
gentiment
je préfère être à ma place sincèrement
parce que c'est vrai qu'avant la finale
j'y ai pensé je me suis dit oh la la il
ya le coach qui sera à saint pétersbourg
il ya trois autres joueurs j'aimerais
bien ramener le mois la médaille d'or et
epl quoi comme ça je serais plus
tranquille autant je me ferais charrier
toute l'année mais
non j'ai un bel accueil ils sont
contents que je sois là avec eux et
j'espère qu'on va bien travailler et
progresser ensemble et
voilà on verra mais bon en tout cas
n'ont pour l'instant ya une bonne
ambiance c'est top vous avez déjà gagné
quasiment tous les trophées d'où vient
cette cette soif de toujours vouloir
gagner
je suis comme ça je suis assez
perfectionniste je déteste perdre j'ai
perdu tellement de finale dans la vie
que en fait je veux voir il ya qu une
belle place en fait c'est celle où on
tient la médaille d'or celle où on gagne
ou à la fin d'un tournoi voilà on se dit
c'est bon on a gagné quoi
mais c'est vrai que c'est dur et a eu
tellement de doute de peur de
frustration on peut pas gagner tout le
temps et j'ai tellement appris à perdre
et a appris à gagner que
voilà c'est un enchaînement faut être
faut toujours travailler et puis
c'est l'aboutissement de tout un travail
de toute une vie quoi donc voilà
j'essaie de me donner le maximum à
chaque fois pour atteindre mes objectifs
personnels aussi objectifs d'équipé et
justement c'est beaucoup de changements
pour vous cette saison déjà changement
de club mais également chargé de sceller
changement de sélectionneur à la tête de
l'équipe de france
concrètement quels sont vos objectifs
l'objectif voilà il a été très clair
bernardinho lors de la première réunion
il a dit qu'il fallait gagner 2024 quoi
paris 2024 il va tout faire pour même
s'il ya plein de compétitions qui vont
arriver là derrière les championnats du
monde qui va être en russie
lui les focus sur sur paris 2024 surtout
que là c'est les jeux à la maison c'est
quelque chose d'incroyable
c'est le c'est l'objectif numéro un de
ce coach et de notre groupe pourquoi pas
faim pourquoi pas rêver d'un doublé ce
sera incroyable mais la route est encore
longue
[Musique]